elle donne envie de faire l'émission en
tout cas ça donne envie de parler de
survie peut-être que je vais la faire il
ya suis ravi bien il ya pour l jospin
qui veut venir maintenant non imagine
chirac l'un bon alors il sympa chirac on
lui donne une bière
jiechi la seule bière
bien alors maintenant mes enfants on va
faire un petit peu de promotion
c'est bien mais continue le sait rien
elle
mignano
bon alors le spectacle donc ailier
semoun alors je donne les dates
maintenant parce qu'il n'ya pas que les
par ici nous l'a dit c'est mission
racine ronde alors le 28 mars à
marseille le 5 avril à clermont ferrand
le 7 8 et 9 avril au casino de paris à
paris et le 13 avril à lyon exact alors
vous fait salle comble partout c'est
pour ça que je voudrais pas ce qu'il
vaut mieux acheter les billets c'est
vrai si on est assis par terre c'est pas
des mensonges lors d'une cassette aussi
donc que je monte alors c'est le
spectacle est lié semoun qui est mise en
scène par muriel robin et donc comme
elie vous l'a dit tout à l'heure il faut
vraiment y aller parce qu'après il va
faire un nouveau spectacle mais après je
vais faire les petites annonces voilà
alors les gens après le spectacle des
fois bien de vous voir et vous dise
il ya des trucs des fois qu'ils sont un
peu durs quoi et vous faites des petits
ajustements ça vous arrive oui enfin
disons en belgique j'ai essayé de faire
le rigolo ça n'a pas fonctionné
je le verrais toutes les vannes alors
c'est parce que j'ai un sketch je fais
une sorte de vieux beau qui se tâtent
une petite fille jeune fille etc puis à
un moment je fais oui non pas la tête et
je les rencontrais chez jean mimi chant
michel n'ont pas la tête et à la 14 ans
on n'est pas en belgique
donc oui c'est que là bas quand même
dans le genre est enfin on essaye disons
assez grave là bah oui on vous dit on
peut rire de tout mais est-ce qu'on peut
le faire tous les jours avec tout le
monde en fait c'est ça la vraie question
donc obligés de il ya souvent des gens
qui prennent les choses au premier des
dream donc pas vous est jamais arrivé ce
qui est arrivé à timsit n'ont pas encore
du travail oui mais ça c'est un vrai
accident tragique accident du temps
parce qu'ils ils l'ont confondu avec
avec ils sont trompés de cible céramique
mais ça colle donc enfin je pense je
sais pas si les gens savent que ces
gaccio qu'avec le
encore lui alors vous êtes toujours en
tournée quoi pas non mais là ça se
termine on peut dire à votre femme que
c'est fini chérie je rentre à la maison
et alors quand vous rentrez chez vous
vous retrouvez vos serre parce que ce
que vous ne savez pas danser les
spectateurs c'est que il y fait pousser
il fait pousser dans des serres écoute
si tu m'a invité à cette émission pour
[ __ ] de ma gueule
écoutez
lorsque je je revendique l'amour des
plantes tropicales voilà aussi des
plantes tropicales la marijuana vous
appelez à prendre
là qu'ils sont bons alors désormais donc
vous travaillez sans la personne de
couleur qui vous accompagnait avant ça
se passe plutôt bien
ça se passe plutôt bien quand je
m'énerve ancien super épanouie mais ça
fait longtemps que je sois vu comme ça
avec la pêche c'est vrai un bail la
personne
me fera taire ah bon
et ça je n'ai jamais les enterrer je me
suis fait
un nom